good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast we hope you had a
wonderful fourth of July spent you know
laughing drinking smiling sweating the
usual good times now it's been a minute
since he sat in these chairs but you
know time flies when you're not working
time flies so much when you have to rub
I was just so concerned as to how I
would preoccupy myself you know during
the long holiday we really like concern
I was concerned cuz I had a long break
and I wasn't going anywhere but the time
just flew and here we are here we are so
much happened wow so much happened
here's what didn't happen I do not get
tan but here's what happened now I can't
believe the words that are about to come
out of my mouth but do you know who I
saw this weekend yes do you know murder
yes I swear on my life I was 10 feet
from Cuba Gooding jr. and I just can't
believe it like I I mean the universe is
so [ __ ] up and everyone around me was
freaking out I like really felt nothing
I really felt like you know I have the
power you know yeah and it was so crazy
I mean I just can't believe that he's
like out and about like living his life
like that's true like male narcissism
like thinking you can just like do
whatever you want like at a party in the
Hamptons it was just it was shocking
like it was truly like seeing a ghost
well you didn't engage with him no of
course not hidden even look my way
what's so scary is that he probably has
no idea who I am right that is what's so
scary
that's just so crazy but nothing of note
happened you're feeling okay I'm feeling
great nothing if not having everyone
around looks boy I'm like sit the [ __ ]
down okay
totally I'm like just shut up and eat
okay totally it was so crazy like and I
just I just couldn't wait to tell the
toasters yeah
they're so invested in this story for
you cuz it's crazy I can't maybe you
didn't tell people sooner like on your
story or anything well you know I was
thinking of being like drama like Edie
but I don't know I just I so don't want
this to be my legacy
like I want to stop talking about it
yeah and good thing like no one like
writes about this show right I'm every
day basis so it's real
safe space for us to talk about stuff it
is I always forget like when I say it
here like I'm saying something like in a
public forum but like nobody ever talks
about us so it's fine right but if you
say it on your Instagram then it gets we
try to center around Rio then they you
said it like as the source yeah no this
is truly a safe space but this show is
like too long for people to go into and
get well but I seven at the top I should
have waited like 10 minute you should
have but while we're at the top of the
show I just want to reconfirm that it is
a toast exclusive that Olivia Coco and
Christian McCaffrey have been spotted
together a pretty sure they're on
vacation yet ever now with their couple
friend that's married and I just I know
there was an NFL podcast out there that
cited the morning toast as Christian
McCaffrey dating Olivia culpo and I just
want you to sort I just want to double
down on that and you say they mean I'm
sure they're dating and it's a toast
exclusive everything is a toast
exclusive I was just going through my
time hop and apparently one year ago
today someone saw Halley and Justin in
the Bahamas and she was wearing a ring I
mean I was only a year ago and it makes
me like think like we really break
everything yeah
and this today's news that was broken by
the toasters is the Camilla Kibeho Shawn
Mendes of it all cuz I was seeing all
weekend in the toast group and I have a
lot of thoughts about people at parties
with them and then there was also some
pictures online like TMZ but I didn't
need TMZ because I got it from the
toaster the TMT and speaking of TMT very
exciting we announced on our Instagram
last night we are having a huge merch
launch tomorrow big summer merch launch
a lot of the products that you guys have
been asking for new products best
sellers will be back in stock and
finally we will have our sorority
crewnecks back in stock apparently we
sold so many crew necks that the man who
makes the crew necks run out of through
that yeah he ran out of the materials to
make routing so we had to make more crew
necks and now there are more clinics I
do think there is a limited stock of the
crew necks just because you know we've
run this a mass production issue we will
always restock them as they become
available but if you really want one now
would be the time to get them some fun
summer items that are dropping as you
know the jewel skin is coming the
controversial jewel skin towels for the
beach bunch of different bright a toasty
sorority towels did with jacuzzis we did
koozies oh and my day that was the most
requested item ever but this was an item
nobody requested but everyone might love
the flag yes we have now an official
toast
that will be into the new logo it's so
cute like it's so toasty it can be take
or you could frame it put it on the back
of your boat I don't know it's such a
summer summer item like I just want to
see people like in the back of the
pickup truck holding up our flag I'm so
excited for the content we're gonna get
like every time merch cup we do the
merchant like two weeks later everyone
gets their stuff and there's like one
day where it starts where everyone's
packages start coming and we get like
cute outfit pictures but I think we are
gonna get the most premium like koozie
boat flag by with the Jackie O flow
preset on top it is perfection coming we
have new prop sockets old pop sockets
it's just gonna be a real it's like
honestly I think this is our biggest
drop yet it is and I'm actually super
excited for our new pop socket it says
here's the thing the thing is and I
don't think there's anything more
pertinent to the situation than that
design I think what might be more
pertinent to the situation is our cross
to bear so much yes oh my wait meets so
many products so many products coming up
it's your [ __ ] cross to there that we
have so many products coming out not
only that but we actually already
figured out our next merch drop and it
is so [ __ ] person and that's gonna be
the best fun should I say you know I
don't ya know cuz I yes okay look we
haven't gotten the ball rolling so you
just don't want to wear the queens of
like making announcements and then not
having it happen like we announced that
we were getting a toastie headquarters
office and like literally that day the
real estate broker emailed me and he's
like oh sorry we can't write you the
unit and we're like why anyone tell us
why yeah he ghosts in the [ __ ] out of me
I know I think it's cuz they have heard
we were planning on starting a sitcom
there and they just didn't wanna be
alone do I really can't think of a
reason he tried to make it seem like we
were being difficult cuz we just wanted
to paint the wall so I said okay we want
paint give me the contract I never heard
from him again no I think he watch
episode we were like talking about him
and like the Russian guy in the and the
the stockbrokers and maybe that people
are doing like business they don't want
publicize whatever so we're still 19
we're still in the Missouri they're
watching this part now we were like
ready to move in like that was really
annoying so we're still in the market
for an office space but like it's hard
time finding commercial real estate it's
really hard
Chile anyways long weekend lots of news
so we obviously will hit you with the
fast life stories I don't feel as though
it is time yet
me neither um look so just like personal
weekend news so I had a really nice
relaxing weekend here in the city I
watched a lot of content and I want to
talk about the highlights which I
haven't talked about even on my story
but I watched Chernobyl on HBO and I
think it needs to be the toe show of the
week it's a it's a miniseries five or
six episodes it's so unbelievably
important and pertinent to the situation
now you know me I'm the queen of not
knowing anything and I don't know what
goes on in the world and it's actually
really sad and I mean a conscious effort
a few years ago to stop knowing about
what was going on in the world because
it was too depressing and now I feel
like I don't know enough and it's just
like my social service missed it civil
civil service see I don't know anything
to know what's going on the world and
what is going on in Chernobyl like is it
good or is it bad
okay it happened in the 80s oh it was
and what I knew vaguely turn over like
no one lives there some psych radiation
explosion a nuclear plant exploded and
the radiation is like off the charts
like people who live people who work
that like put out the fire like died
within days oh but people who lived
there and then the surrounding areas
like have got developer forms of cancer
from like the radioactive material that
went into the air it was a crazy thing
you guys should watch the rotaries and
it was just so well done okay like
justice for lane Pryce from Mad Men who
plays the guy who needs justice but I
don't know his Russian name okay um
anyway so twisters I would highly
suggest that then I obviously got into a
bit of Lifetime movie club I saw Jason
Momoa you know what I started that movie
it was so [ __ ] bad I couldn't finish
it oh my god it was so bad we also did
you see Becca Tobin is in a hallmark
movie I did see did you watch it
no because is it not a Christmas movie
no it premiered live and like everyone
was tweeting about it oh my god [ __ ] I
will be watching yeah I know like that
is like like the culmination of your
life no a hundred percent I'm actually
with Becca Tobin on the Hallmark Channel
culmination of my life was a movie on my
time would be club starring Liz Gillies
Oh was there one yes called killing
daddy and then it's where the guns I
realized I'd seen it before wow that's
creepy
crazy eating of Liz Gillies another huge
update from this weekend is our best
friend Kristen got engaged
and just couldn't be happier and I
almost ruined it you almost did well
because your drum self I woke up and I
had a known AMA drug self why what what
did I do
oh well we tell me what you think you
did no I was just saying how like I
didn't action I'm a surgeon and I was
just being paranoid cuz I won't really
vivid dream about Kristen and Pete and I
woke up and I had a text from Kristen it
was just so weird and I was like telling
her about how she's like on my mind and
I had this dream better and I just
thought like I made it really obvious oh
that's not you when I'm talking what did
I do
apparently when you facetimed her to say
congratulations like you don't realize
that the party the next day was a
surprise huh so you were like I'm so sad
I can't be there and she like then was
like oh is something going on oh I
didn't know that she didn't know when
and whatever hit my defense I had such a
weird weekend where all day Friday I
thought it was Saturday and I thought I
was going home the next day so I was
like not gonna drink so much because I
had to drive home and then I'm like oh
wait now I can drink all I want
tomorrow's only Saturday so oh [ __ ] I
feel bad no but the engagement is the
surprise you know and everything else is
just the cherry on top so also she
didn't know she thought she was doing
something Saturday night but then we
were all at her apartment Saturday they
surprised her on Saturday but then
Saturday night I wasted a good two hours
of my life seeing the movie yesterday
and I just need to let everyone know to
not see it it was the waters [ __ ]
movie I ever saw
I couldn't stop talking to Zach during
the movie like oh my god it was good it
was so bad the premise was was stupid
but you could maybe get past that like I
don't need it to make all make sense
right the premise was so stupid and at a
certain point it like got weirdly
depressing Lily James like he's an awful
actress
oh yeah and then she's a lot of
potential she never really become
potential she started Cinderella with
Robb Stark that went nowhere yeah Mamma
Mia - don't get me started yes and now
this movie and it was just so bad in
such a waste of time and now I have to
imagine how it came to be because like
who needed this movie no one but we've
been talking about music rights and we
all know that the Beatles don't own
their own Michael Jackson yeah like it's
a corporate thing so I think they wanted
to make a movie with Beatles music so
they were like how do we do that but
they want to make new songs because
they can't have the Beatles sing right
so they were like let's have this guy
see the songs in a world where the
Beatles yeah you never explained why the
Beatles didn't exist
it was so [ __ ] stupid don't waste
your time don't waste I thought it was
like at least your allowance I thought
it was gonna be a like type of movie
where was all a dream
that would have been even stupider I
think that's exactly was saying in the
middle I was like please you know okay
so it's not so it's not oh no because
then it's like we just watched someone
the street you know I don't even like
watching my own dreams yeah an edge here
and was in it and it's like Justice
French here and he didn't deserve that I
have to toe somebody a lot of people in
the YouTube comments are saying hey look
so good today and I do have to apologize
because I didn't you Instagram Q&A today
and I told the world your big dark
secret which is why your hair is from a
box
hey everyone said is Jackie's natural
hair I said it's from a box you did I
did I told the world you're Big C I
didn't even tag me so like that's sorry
I said I actually didn't see it um my
hair is like not from a box
color-wise but sometimes the hair itself
no I'm at the color it's from a bag it's
a lorry Oh a bag full of hair it's a
L'Oreal Bucks I told everyone you're
such a snitch even and the liar at that
some box am I missing something
no it's just I'm just being with you but
your hair's not from a box obviously I
just like one to start off and I did
[Laughter]
count fire box hair okay I guess I hear
someone box now no it's up a rock so
it's kind of necessary and drama I just
like what make sure dragon you Joe got a
little too long no we're good no we're
good we're good but your hair is so long
I'm kidding it's having a box you guys
relax
you know it's Monday morning sure sorry
do we have an ad for an air box no it's
a Monday morning [ __ ] start okay well do
you feel as though it's time it's been
12 minutes let me check my have a lot to
talk about a lot of news has happened
let me check my phone it's 1042 I think
it's time I think it's time snitch what
do you think I think it's time okay
without further ado okay buddy here's
our the fast side stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning
I mean it is time don't get me Ryan but
I do feel as though I would be remiss if
I didn't let everyone know that today's
very prestigious episode of the morning
toast is brought to you by skill share
an online learning community with
thousands of amazing classes covering
dozens of creative and entrepreneurial
skills you can take classes in
everything from photography and creative
writing to design productivity and more
so whether you're returning to a
longtime passion project challenging
yourself to get outside your comfort
zone or simply exploring something new
Skillshare has classes for you I take a
mole on Skillshare about mobile
photography and now we're thinking we
have a new intern she's just been
promoted to PA maybe it's time for her
to get on Skillshare so I'm gonna say
you got Margot give you a couple credits
you use our link you maybe take a mobile
photography maybe like a journal it's
something I don't know you should
photoshop we've really loved Skillshare
so many of you have as well and now it's
the cistern and there's an endless
amount of classes to choose from which
is just so exciting you can join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for our listeners you can get two
months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering the morning
toast listeners two months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare dot-com
slash morning toast
again that's Skillshare dot-com slash
morning toast to start your two months
now Skillshare commie slash morning
toast exciting times okay first story so
exciting the u.s. women's soccer team
wins the World Cup title for a fourth
time it's not every day that we start
with some sports news no it's not every
day that we start with some sports news
and I actually found myself to be just
like watching the games like knowing
that it was on on Sunday and then the
one before that was like a Thursday I am
so involved I mean I think I'm on the
team I think I'm the goalie yeah you
really are invested in this team so I'm
gonna throw to you okay how are you
feeling so they beat the Netherlands two
to zero like please you make it all the
way the world covering our team with
score gold losers and I just I'm feeling
so excited and I'm feeling like I just
love a moment where like the world is
all watching one thing you know and it
just feels very exciting that America
won cuz like we're the most obese
country in the world you know here we
are like winning soccer games right and
it's like we're probably the country
that prioritizes after the least yet
we're sent in on these hope that's so
true that must be like so upsetting for
like the football clubs in Europe like
us Americans with our soccer
we care like we pay our women like three
cents on the dollar and they still want
no totally oh I mean now I'm so invested
in this whole Equal Pay you see they
filed a motion now I have a couple
questions I know look a little bit about
it but they're filing a motion is the
u.s. like soccer league is that like a
government organization are they doing
it through the government you know
filing a motion through the government
cuz it's a legal thing so they're not
asking the government for money no it's
in the league but the league is not like
it's like the US team so like it's like
the Olympics probably take the NFL is
private right but this is like a world
thing so then how could it be the
government I don't know it is another
thing you must stop feeling a private
company I think so okay I think so now I
put on my story I have to get into this
because I'm now coming with facts and
you know if you know me you know I do a
lot of things but I don't have facts but
today I have that she came through she
came prepared because I put on this
story about like the the discrepancy
between the payment of the women and the
men's is so crazy and it's even made
even more crazy by the fact that the men
literally have never made it to the
World Cup like let alone they make it
they lose like 16 rounds out this is
literally the premise of bring it on
when the cheerleader is getting no
respect there's a football team second
half so the discrepancy between the men
and the female salaries is as such
female soccer players this is from The
Huffington Post female soccer players
base salary is roughly $30,000 less than
their male counterparts at US soccer
they also earn a much smaller bonus in
the World Cup so if the women win the
World Cup they have 15 grand if the men
do they win 55 grand and here's the
stark comparison the Soccer League
awarded the men's team of five million
dollar bonus when it lost at the round
of 16 in the 2014 World Cup the women's
team won and they made 1.7 million
dollars so men made five four losing
like in the very beginning women made
1.7 so I just put this interesting
factoid on my story because I thought it
was well interesting and I got really
shocking and out of gm's especially from
women just being like know your facts
like the men's league is more ratings
more people watch it makes more money
therefore they earn the same percentage
of a bigger pot so I'm like damn that
kind of makes like you know sense and
maybe I'm not be flogged okay wait I
need to find this it's a lot a lot and
yes I'm looking for yeah no but it was
in the main
group she came with her [ __ ] thing I
think he might even toast after dark
sucker hold on I need to find it okay
take your time even though I have to
imagine that that's not true because
like no oh my god not only are not doing
more women stop us women soccer players
said I know by name I don't know any men
except for David Beckham and he's not
even us no I mean I can't find their
whelmed so he wrote about a pedophile
give me a second okay this is a quote
from for it's it's Statistics taken from
the file they motioned no the motion is
high both the women have played 19 more
games than the men in the last three
years on top of additional games they
have many more appearances and media
tours than the men because they bring in
much more revenue than the men aka more
work if it were not for the woman's us
the women's team USSF would be $400,000
in the hole but instead they have a 17
million dollar profit margin thanks to
the ladies the women's team has the
highest viewership of the u.s. of any
soccer team in the world their Jersey is
Nikes most popular selling jersey in
history unless we forget that the men
didn't even qualify for the last World
Cup our girls bring in more money for
the USSF than the men do at Point Blank
but everyone's like look men have more
ratings like all around the world but
this is America yeah so I just was like
wanted to clarify like because there's
been a lot of like you know fake news
around the subject but oh I have to say
it's tell if she's so ahead of the curve
yes maybe yeah was that at the one we
were at yes Abby Wambach yeah yeah and
that was like four years ago now right
yeah yeah I just been like thinking
about this team so much because I was
watching other and Stremme stories and
then like in their locker room like in
their jerseys like dirty like sweaty
like just like drinking beer and
celebrating like eating apples like
that's what athletes do and I was like
truly having fellow even though like I
don't know them know it's amazing
justice for the women of women's soccer
truly but I feel everything that I've
seen everyone's on the same page about
how they leave has now agreed to go into
mediation they're not gonna take it to
trial they're gonna settle good yes
we're always being like embarrassed in
the worldwide global arena and it's like
here the women of America are like
finally giving justice to us like we're
being taken seriously in a European
sport and like we're giving them a
dollar no no not gonna fight
not gonna fly okay are you ready for the
next story I don't know I just like
really wanted
talking about the USWNT they'll probably
keep coming up I mean you know it feels
very pertinent cuz I don't know if you
guys know Jackie and I grew up playing
soccer like this could have been us this
could have been us like if we had played
our cards right yeah like we're good
yeah and I didn't gain weight
Mia Hamm season yeah Jackie's like icon
as Mia Hamm I think it was like your
password no totally I loved her it was
definitely one of my screening yes
screen name yeah yeah sorry I'm like out
here til I get word your password it's
me I am one two three
she where does Mia Hamm up to I think
she's just being a legend yeah yeah just
be nice yeah must be nice
hang on her box of Wheaties you know
who's you Serena Williams is now in a
box Wheaties thank God for Dan I know
I'm like shook yeah dead it's news ya
know that it had to happen that he was
still around but that's true when you
think of Wheaties who do you think Bruce
Jenner yeah okay next story we must
discuss like some really sad news
Cameron Boyce served Disney Channel's
descendants dead at 20 Cameron Boyce to
appeared in Disney child TV series
Jessie and the network's descendants
franchise has died at the age of 20
quotas with profoundly heavy heart
they'll be report this morning we lost
Cameron a spokesperson for his family
told ABC News quote he passed away in
his sleep due to a seizure seizure which
was a result of an ongoing medical
condition for which he was being treated
the world is now undoubtedly without one
of its brightest lights but his spirit
will live on through the kindness and
compassion of all who knew him the
statement continued we are utterly
heartbroken and asked for privacy during
this immensely difficult time as we
grieve the loss of our precious son and
brother Boyce who also starred in grown
ups with Adam Sandler had appeared in
other Disney Channel shows including Liv
and Maddie and good luck charlie okay if
you have ever seen one minute of disney
channel you know who Cameron voices he
was in everything just like seemed like
such a secret yet see reading all of
these tributes so sad so shocking like
when I saw the news I was like what cuz
like what like 20 minutes just don't I
know so sad and then I realized like
really the scope of his work that he was
even so much more than Disney Channel
like Sam Hayek is out here putting up a
post for him I think he was in grown-ups
like he really had such a bright future
ahead of him he really did and everyone
had just the kind like obviously you
only have nice things to say about
someone when they pass away but like the
way that people were talking on about
him he seems like an angel on yes yeah
and this is the saddest story it's so
sad for like all of the the whole Disney
Channel family the posts like Peyton
lists posted everyone takes like
everyone knows him and it's
heartbreaking so sad and like oh I mean
I don't think anyone wants to ask that
question or talk about the fact that
it's we're not getting any real
information just because it's still such
a raw sad time but hopefully eventually
we'll get answers because this doesn't
just happen no 20 year olds just don't
die in their sleep it's literally the
saddest thing ever
James II just put out an article saying
that he suffer from epilepsy seizure
yeah but the family had said he had an
ongoing medical condition ongoing no I
know but they could have just said right
whatever
um so sad I just I can't believe it like
he's such a little cutie I know him from
Jessie yes can't something about to have
Cameron like Sophia Carson are they
gonna be okay
no and descendants 3 premieres August
3rd he's a part of a franchise on Disney
Channel in case it's a high-school
mobile this generation yeah and they're
about to go into like press and
everything it comes out in in three
weeks I know they were just gonna start
yeah so I didn't realize August service
literally in three weeks I thought it
was still May mom so it's just gonna be
such a sad time like such a bittersweet
thing to do awful you see Kenny Ortega
supposed he 3 so many times very sad so
sad sky Jackson McLean I can't no so sad
like I don't even like when something
like this happens it's just like shakes
you you know yeah so yeah it's just who
died like him like I just like never
know it's so crazy and it's so sad and
he was such a little cutie yes so we're
thinking of his family and his friends
and the whole Disney community and we'll
keep you posted if any more info comes
out but right now it's just sad yeah
okay well back to some more positive
news lil mermaid has been cast oh my god
I need some and the internet people are
in a park
a tizzy but Hallie Bailey has been cast
as The Little Mermaid okay anyone else
when they first saw him I probably Barry
yeah yeah yeah like they let her have
the same name yeah okay because I only I
only know her as Halle because of Chloe
X Halle didn't know her license I went
through three stages when I heard it I
mean I'm at Halle Berry what and then
I'm like oh Halle Bailey I don't know
where then I'm like oh wait Chloe you're
right okay
like literally took me she sang at the
Super Bowl and she [ __ ] crushed yeah
it took me a 75 years to realize so when
they were talking about you know right
and I'm so excited about damn so say
we're getting closer to a casting this
guy thing has been like the most
contentious process and it was already
cast as Lea Michele and I know that was
the Hollywood Bowl anyway no I know but
I thought that was like a foray into her
bigger role oh no this is that was like
Broadway and a right cat each person
it's like everyone has a say in
everything it's like Li Xue and Melissa
McCarthy Karthi were both up for Ursula
I feel like we never it's not until
after the movie is made to be find out
who was in the running do they do they
cast our soy yet Melissa McCarthy okay
people were like upset about it cuz it
wasn't listening but I love Melissa
McCarthy it would have been great as
listen now like Terry Crews is is vying
for the role of King Triton which is but
it's like since when does Ed is this
just a dear it's a mother oh it's a
free-for-all like this isn't [ __ ]
Chirac receipt is your movie and we will
come watch it okay and unfortunately I
have to talk about the like the backlash
of casting Holly Bailey which is so
crazy first of all could she be more
beautiful one no two on her first
mixtape she was wearing a mermaid tail
did you see yet two three she can sing
like that's literally all I really
actually required for everyone's like
it's not okay areas why I'm like artists
a [ __ ] mermaid that's not accurate
either it's so stupid like I can't even
like an in-depth conversations people
are having about this like really going
toe to toe like because they're stand
firm in their belief like what
it's a [ __ ] mermaid relax relax
freeform who commented sometimes I
thought was so funny I mean they wrote
the original off yes the original author
of The Little Mermaid was Danish Arielle
Tasha Todd is a mermaid she lives in an
underwater Kingdom in international
waters and can legit swim wherever she
wants even though that often upsets King
Triton comet absolutes
okay they're just try but for the sake
of the argument let's say that Arielle -
is Danish Danish mermaids can be black
because Danish people can be black
Arielle Tain's sneak up to the surface
at any time with her pal scuttle and the
Jamaican crab Sebastian and keep that
bronze base tight black Danish people
and thus merfolk can also genetically
have red hair but spoiler alert bring it
back to the top the character of Ariel
is a work of fiction no it's so stupid
and I just think it's a great casting
like I'm loving an emerging new talent
you know she's so young but I my mind
immediately went what about Chloe I know
it's awkward I don't think so I think
this is like you know you don't always
think they're yeah they've gotten super
far together but maybe they want to
explore different things like maybe
holly has this acting passion maybe
Chloe you know wants to do the solo
route like he and I totally but it's
just like this is the biggest thing like
in the world like this this type of
casting like changes people's lives
yes and it's like she got famous off of
being a duo it's just like it's all
thing the Jonas Brothers but never know
never they'll be like if I got cast in
Hairspray well you would have to get to
cast no that would be a penny Pingleton
Jo was in Camp Rock and he didn't come
for his brother
right right right he made sure they were
in it right so but I think this is good
I mean this is can't be anything but
good like the it's a launching platform
no it's so great and now I'm looking at
the Disney landscape and Disney for
years has been really heavily criticized
for not being inclusive like when you
look at the lineup of Disney Princesses
there wasn't a black Disney Princess I
think till 2009 and now look at the
landscapes like we have Lion King with a
mostly black cast and now a black area I
think it's great I mean for I think it's
great like this is [ __ ] Cara you
everyone is so wild like it's gonna be a
great movie yeah sit down
Oh maybe you know what maybe now that we
have a black area like she can carry a
tune you know what I was thinking I know
that I'm supposed to relate to REO but I
don't think I've ever seen the whole
movie you know what I don't really know
what the shows about
like like I only know no I'm getting it
confused with alcohol Maureen she yeah
she has to fall in love on land she has
a strict dad that's what I know okay and
she was underwater and she's a crab
friend okay choice crabs I choose crabs
I've never seen the whole movie this
will be the first time that I do and I'm
excited
see it I'm all about season II like I'm
all about redhead representation yet
that never happened for me
did you see Aladdin no but Zach said it
was amazing really you know I feel like
Disney movies when they come out are
like huge spectacles like everyone
everything I haven't heard or seen it's
like they've done any commercials no I
suck the commercials make it look
terrible
okay um but then and I wouldn't be
interested um but Zach loved it so much
I felt that way about Dumbo - it's like
it was this whole thing and then it came
out silent like oh did I gotta see Dumbo
yeah it's not even in theaters anymore
yeah where the commercials where the
busses with billboards I don't know
we're gonna get on bus
I think it's cuz we're all just looking
down like you just miss it that's our
through but then there wasn't any
influence or partnerships cuz I didn't
see the in partner with any famous
elephants there was no influence or
partnerships that's why I didn't see it
that's why I didn't see it look they
didn't have courting her - Lee with her
kids at the premiere no romance it it's
true I saw Madison this weekend when I
was young that's just [ __ ] Jim yeah
her content was good in the words of
Sonja Morgan we always have a good time
that's so nice
yeah um on the same we're like I start
drinking water to someone I'm trying to
get my life back together like eating
how they take vitamins all that stuff um
and I've literally never had to pee more
that's good that means that you're
hydrated no I know but like when they
tell you to drink more water like
wedding useless to pee yeah well I
actually read an article not recently
that was like how to know if you're
drinking enough water and you can
measure based on how you pee if you're
peeing every thirty minutes you're
drinking too much water okay but like
and then had it like how do you drink so
much water and then now I woke up at
7:00 in the morning so you have to pee
like that's so in a way you can't drink
water right before bed that's the
problem that's all - right before bed
okay Theo you're like Thea truly I'm
really just like I've been on like a
bender
these past like a couple weeks where I'm
like eating like a slob drinking and
just like not taking care of myself so
like today's the day I drink a full
bottle of Seltzer Seltzer is counts
right yes it's Elster's water
I had a daily harvest like smoothie like
moment this morning and I'm just really
working on getting my mind body and soul
right daily harvest is exactly what you
need because it has so many nutrients
and it's easy to make and a smoothie
will hydrate right up so daily harvest
delivers thoughtfully sourced chef's
crafted food that is built on fruits and
vegetables and can be prepared in less
than five minutes
fill your box with more than 65
different options like ready to blend
smoothies refreshing chilled soups and
savory harvest bowls that's what I had
today everything stays fresh
your freezer until you're ready to eat
it each jelly harvest cup takes one step
to prepare with room for customization
you can add your favorite milk to a
smoothie or blend have heat you can heat
up a harvest ball top with an avocado or
a fried egg the best part is that daily
harvest single strip cups are the
ultimate grab-and-go meal or snack so
you can get a dose of nourishing fruits
and vegetables at any time of the day go
to daily harvest calm and enter promo
code toast to get three cups free in
your first box that's promo code toast
toas tea for three free daily harvest
cups at daily harvest calm that's daily
harvest dot-com I love daily harvest I
see a lot of your writing that you had a
rough weekend and I just I can't suggest
it strongly enough at least we can set
me back like a good year I'm sorry well
you have to get your [ __ ] together
because we're going away this weekend we
run with nit debate into this weekend
like this week is my week yeah I'm not
gonna do anything different but I'm just
gonna say hey Lee Harvey I'll help you
guys okay next story is really exciting
Shawn Mendes and Camilla caballo fuel
romance rumors with PDA pact brunch okay
all weekend people were speculating are
they aren't they
they were seen dancing and a party
together you know a lot that we're at a
diner together but like there was no
hard facts that they were dating like
everything looks like speculation and
also looks like okay maybe they hooked
up but like yeah that doesn't mean that
they're dating he did a fan Q&A like at
one point this weekend with some of his
like intimate fans in a place in LA and
one of the fans were like are you dated
Camilla and he said no right right well
today pictures have just come out of
them going to brunch together or holding
hands like being couple E as [ __ ] and
also clearly in the public like they
don't care who sees it right so a lot of
people are like 1 they're just friends
or a lot of you're like it's thick promo
for senorita
well sending me there already came out
so that would be bad problem because you
would do the promo before and 2 if they
were being thirsty promo they would be
like up the paparazzi's ask everything
I've seen has been like a blurry picture
on someone's phone in the toaster screw
up like that's how you know it's real
because they're not thirsting like on a
red carpet or like in a very public
place start like a small diner him going
the Met Gala with Haley Baldwin right
like let's just fake is fun and by the
way if this is fake he learned his
lesson because that was so overtly
obvious and stupid now he's like going
the total opposite like let's go to a
dungeon and see if anyone sees us
yeah also um I don't I don't
I don't think this is sick I would I
would feel really stupid if they found
out that this mistake but they just
seemed to be going about in a really
normal way also I understand if you're
in a PR relationship you have
obligations you have to walk on this
carpet together bla bla bla but to spend
your holiday weekend with someone like
as you know going to parties and like
partying it's a little that's so extra
like you don't have to give up your
whole life you just have to do a few
things for your fake early you know
that's a great call and when I think
about the genesis of their relationship
obviously this makes a lot of sense
because when they both were starting out
Camilla was on her solo grind in the
very beginning she had like that one
song with Machine Gun Kelly and then she
came out with that song with oh no this
was before she left with her me she had
a song with Shawn Mendes I know he did
last summer and it was so good I'm like
they're the perfect couple like and they
didn't date then and I was like if it
didn't happen then I'm like oh it's
never gonna happen for them they're
actually just friends but now it's like
they have another song together they're
probably spending a lot of long nights
in the studio dancing to senorita
together like what are you gonna do no
and he's definitely grown up you know
when they recorded that person the boys
12 and now he's 13 no and not only is he
13 he's the hottest 13 year old I've
ever met like I needed him at my bar
mitzva I love him so much I really love
her like I've been a fight fifth harmony
stance since the very beginning but more
importantly I've always been a Camilla
stand because I always knew when
watching her on x-factor like she was so
supremely talented so much better so
much more elevated than everyone else
and she got put in the strip like my
mistake and if Simon's fault but she
made her way out of the group and now
she's like a huge solo artist and I just
want happiness for her and as she was
taking that guy like man I think I see
like the dating guru like that wasn't it
for her no but she definitely prepared
her for this relationship because I'm
sure like dating and dating her you
learn a lot it's a very healthy
relationship yeah you got a lot of
relationship advice I would assume so
I'm excited about these two also uh I
don't think her being in fifth harmony
was ever a mistake I think she's exactly
where she needs to be you know she's
exactly where she needs to be when you
watched the show she was yeah she it was
a little silly because a Harry Styles
right because more importantly the five
girls who started out in fifth harmony
all auditioned separately they did not
know each other before the show and when
everyone got kicked off they brought
back those girls are like you know what
you're all mediocre but together you
could be good but I really felt like
maybe Camilla didn't do good during like
the boot camp week or she didn't like
nail her audition because for the rest
of the show they would perform and it's
Camilla got every solo Camilla was
clearly star the audience in the
Specter Stadium like went wild when
Camilla sang like it was like the
Camilla show and Demi Lovato even said
like after one performance like you guys
aren't a group it's like literally
Camilla and you're her backup singers
like you guys need to pick pick it up
like it was so weird and like obvious
that she was not meant to be there I
just meant talent was like she was
really never meant to be in a group I
thought I think at all I think she was
it was perfect for then and now she's
doing her own thing but I seem but I
don't think anyone that was good it was
great and I don't think she if she was
just a solo how many solos good singing
girls should we see on talent shows that
go nowhere Carly rose sonenclar tons I'm
just saying like she was never meant to
be in fifth harmony for this long and
and there's a reason why she has the
solo career that she does and Dinah Jane
has a solo career that she does know but
normanni has the solo career that she
does really cuz nobody's been on one
song she's getting there she's getting
there
I'm just I'd like it don't pooh-pooh on
fifth harmony like they were great and
they give us so many box
I'm not pooping I'm just saying like but
they only gave us so many box with
chameleon chameleon the man I'm not I'm
not cuckooing on I'm just say like this
is the life Camilla was supposed to have
yeah running around the show man you
have to work after opening for Taylor
Swift yes yes you have to work together
but I'm just glad she's having their
solo moment that's what I was trying to
say okay agreed well speaking of solo
moments our third and final story is
unbelievably sad well ariana grande
broke down into tears during her concert
I guess so ariana grande was in her
concert in st. Louis on Saturday and she
started crying for real when she started
singing REM and if you watch the video
it's like she cries a lot at her
concerts you know when she sings I wish
I could say I think you know Malcolm he
was an angel okay and there's Sam while
you're tearing up but she's like real
it's like when you start crying and you
can stop look someone's near the lump in
your throat and it gets really dry and
you could swallow it and move on and
keep going but sometimes slim gets too
big and it takes over and the tears come
and like you're done no and she couldn't
stop crying and it was so sad to watch
then she wrote on Twitter which she of
course now deleted Torah is wild life is
wild I'm grateful for the sea of love I
have around me every day and for the
people who come to these shows and give
us all every ounce of energy they've got
I'm grateful to work with the best
musicians and dancers in the world I'm
grateful for my voice in my team I'm
grateful for this music I'm grateful for
my tour bus driver Kurt who bought me
pickles yesterday because he saw we ran
out I'm grateful for the opportunity to
sing to thousands of people every night
it's a dream come true no matter how
hard it gets or how many feelings come
up that are screaming at me to be
processed and sorted
through one day I'm grounded by
gratitude and promise not to give up on
what I've started it's so weird because
when she addresses her fans she really
speaks from like this healthy mental
state and like she really like she knows
like she's been through a lot like it
doesn't happen overnight like she's
still processing it but then what you
see is so much different than what she
says you know I mean to me she looks
like a girl who's breaking down who
needs to take a nap yeah
but she I think she has the option to
take a nap you know I don't think
there's anyone who's forcing her to be
on this tour she's a big enough star
that the whole world would understand if
she stopped but I think she enjoys being
distracted but then sometimes like it
gets to her help but now I wonder why
REM Marga what are the words to that
song as it is particularly sad song it's
a song that she actually broke before
she met Pete about like where she would
wake up and like have met the person so
I don't it's not a particularly sad song
but maybe was like something about the
lyrics people were saying could relate
to Mack actually and his dad well she
doesn't sing one last time anymore right
she didn't think it at her show it's
time someone told me she doesn't sing
anymore cuz it's like the Manchester
song yeah which just sucks is such a
great song but I also became terrorists
again ruining everything but I also
think that song we gonna be alright is
it
Manchester song - um but maybe one last
time it's just too old like you know
it's not like a bob yeah she does send
break free she doesn't sing piano which
is like probably the greatest loss of
all time there was a period where ariana
grande was like really fresh out of
Nickelodeon and like wasn't being taken
serious as a songstress in the pop world
and she was just like releasing music
for the sake of releasing music
honeymoon Avenue and like I think she
likes to gloss over that part of her
career like it doesn't exist when I just
feel like I want to put it out there
that it's probably the best part of had
cute heart amazing having you is an
incredible song and if I hit harmony
rendition that they did on YouTube is
even better acapella yeah no I
completely agree where should she that
doesn't really like that musics
showcased her voice so well right like
before dangerous woman it was just like
her being really excited about making
music and having a [ __ ] amazing voice
and just wanted to put out pop you take
that highlight of it yeah I think the
only song that survived from that era
was the way with Mac yes because Mac
Miller was on in now it's like their
song they have that cute music video but
other than that like she and she also
had another so
that was like a big chart-topper at the
time that she that just completely well
what's so interesting is what people
don't realize is ariana grande in a lot
of ways was responsible for the launch
of the weekend agreed because he was on
lovely harder right yeah yeah and it's
like we were like who's this guy and why
does he have crazy hair and then he like
took off in his own way but like let's
me not forget where he came from
Ariana Grande Volodya he would have
taken off regardless yes but she
catapulted it but yeah she was just the
first like that was how a lot of us were
introduced right exciting yeah just
interesting factoids that I find to be
well I don't know
interesting totally agree that whole
album where she's sitting on the stool
what's that one called my everything my
everything yes yes lays over that one
too is that into you or is that
dangerous dangerous woman I think she
really is so there's a writer I had a
log of music she doesn't she doesn't
it's like right now when we're talking
about it seems like she does but then
sometimes you're listening to her on
shuffle and it's like what's this crap
right you know hold on see discography
my everything oh she has an album called
yours truly Oh problem like she never
sings that anymore I don't like I hate
focus vodka soda
yes bang bang she says that to that
album what albums is my everything this
has she carried free one last time best
mistake love me harder what was before
that yours truly and there we have piano
the way I'm the Jew listen to this oh
this song she you probably forgot that
she was out in for a second I was like I
don't know that she was on it popular
song with Mika sure knew where they
sampled popular I'm gonna play it oh no
we're gonna get I know YouTube is gonna
fly us don't you remember Miko right of
course
okay okay I was something called the
popular song I listened to it afterward
is okay but yeah he would never know she
saying that tattooed heart I mean I
could also there's so many things I need
to learn how to ground and use her to
take a nap of them when she wakes up I
really need her to do like an entire
album of Broadway covers like perfect
circular wicked I could really do just
like a you mastered album of like top 10
greatest hits there's just like a lot
that I need from her but I know she's
busy yeah and then to do a concert at
Radio City Music Hall but also to take a
nap 1111 make a wish I wish I ariana
grande
find joy and peace I wish like I was
like right next to a toilet I have to
pee so bad like this has never happened
I know well cuz usually like we're oh no
and I never drink water I'm a lizard
well that was our fifth and final story
the show ain't over because showing I
feel as though there's still so much
more to talk about and I can only do
five stories but there were so many more
things what else I don't like Jeffrey
Epstein oh my god by heard he's taken
everyone down with him I'm very excited
I'm very excited - I need to read up on
everything I've been like reading the
paper but I feel like there's so much on
Andy that would do I know really bring
clarity to a lot of the situation I mean
what's so crazy is that Jeffrey Epstein
I don't even know who he is I just know
him from like reading blogs and knowing
Island
reading yet knowing that he is like the
purveyor of evil and and violence and
just bad so what's so crazy is like this
is emerging of like the real world we're
like celebrities pretend like they don't
have problems and like the dark
underground blinds world like Jeffrey
Epstein is the connector of the - you
know - yeah and it's like this is the
blinds coming to life no this is the
blinds beginning to see yes and Jackie
and I now we said last week we were
gonna do at our first patreon episode of
this month it's gonna be a blinds
episode just cuz we haven't read blinds
and why don't think now it's like July
4th reveal oh right yeah week I've been
saving them because also I want to have
our reactions like to live but there's
nothing better than July 4th that at
crazy days and nights no I was having
flashbacks last year when we learned
that James Dean was still alive right
and that Anna Wintour and problem I have
the love shot no so crazy so that's
gonna be patron upside head to
patreon.com slash Morton chest just a
lot I didn't I didn't read the blinds
either because I do like having natural
reactions on the episode but I'm really
looking forward to what Andy has for us
I know I just love those those lines
that are just full of interesting
factoids it's like no one's going to
jail like no one broke the law but it's
interesting to know who's a [ __ ] like
we're a drunk at what party row row row
right whoo woods we taking home who was
at Coachella face floor topless yeah
that was a good one that'll be really
fun um this week we're here till
Thursday there's a Thursday Friday
Friday we're heading to Vegas for my
birthday so get ready for the most
annoying premium story it's like ever
Friday Saturday Sunday like we are and
here's the thing it's um putting so much
time effort money into planning this
trip I just need everyone who's coming
like all I need for them is a hundred
and ten percent do you think everyone's
gonna give you that
yes yeah we're today's Vegas and like
not that's what they had that's true I
need everything from everyone I'm like
nervous like you know it's like I hate
planning stuff because then it's like if
it's not good it falls on you welcome to
life yes in my life yeah but I've now
taken a backseat I'm saying no to life
now right I'm saying no to the concert
oh my god that's really no I mean my
girl were going to concert on Thursday
but why because it just doesn't work
with my schedule and trying to make it
work we'll just like put me out and I'd
rather I'd rather not all right you know
what else but it's gonna be a great week
your birthday's on Wednesday oh yeah
what do you want to do literally nothing
can we get a facial hey movie Olivia's
birthday was yesterday it was so [ __ ]
fun she's a dinner party which is like
are we 90 like we're really being
elevated to the sex mature level by
Olivia and I'm totally here for it no it
was so wonderful it was just a great use
of birthday time truly I had a great
time
it was good she made tacos mmm delicious
package a man was there of course he was
he was his weekend in the Hamptons being
farm kemon he had a great weekend in the
Hamptons he is just like loves fresh
grass loves to roll around in it he got
a tick we pulled it out it was like so
much drama but he wore his ceresco
collar so he's all good and he took his
heart guard a great weekend you know
he's definitely feeling like you know
when you get home from camp and like
you're depressing mr. camp friends like
that's what he's having now he's at home
depressed it's great oh that is so
[ __ ] sad well so someone asked if we
are recapping Bravo shows housewives
weren't on I watched southern charm I
doubt that you did know I was so when
you cap it with southern charm this week
because it's not weak eyes weren't
almost no fourth like oh I thought I'd
totally missed know everything hills
Lebanon in New York wasn't on
okay so we'll recap this week yeah you
know what he did watch because he had a
Bravo Marathon of blow deck which I've
never really been into the show but I
really got into it I watched below-deck
med this most recent episode with Kate
Chastain and it was just I don't know
what about this season just pulled me in
she's so scary but it was so good and
like honestly the Charter guests are y-z
wild and like so embarrassed and then
Joe you always think about like if you
were a charter guest like what could
they say about you like we like they
would be like oh these fat alcoholics
cuz we would just be drinking and eating
all
like never go into bed and just look I
just it's like embarrassing I can't
believe people would pay I know like a
charter trip of that magnitude cost like
60 to 100 grand but if you do it on
below deck you get it for like 30 grand
which is why the people that go on are
like rich for like not that rich um but
I can't imagine paying money to be made
fun of you know yeah I mean not all of
them are made fun of but there was this
group of girls on the last episode and
they were horrible and even when they
weren't like being overtly I'm not just
just when they got snippets of their
conversation it was like so painful and
that's what's embarrassing and you're
like you guys just suck and then you
also have to be on TV in the bathing
suit yeah but you could you could skate
or skirt around that yeah just like you
know take a cover-up off you slip in
it's such a great show it really it so
now I'm into it and now we've signed
copies of doctor uh captain Lee's book
it's so exciting
so now I'm gonna watch the rest of this
season of yellow deck med or regular
regular okay
because Milla with Mila and Hannah yes
and I know you have lots of feelings
about how just because I thought she was
unfair towards Malika yeah but nobody it
was [ __ ] annoying on he or she has
good Chiefs it's just funny how the
Chiefs used treat people like based on
you know if they're alphas or betas you
know it's like her chief stews this
season are like just nice and do
whatever she says in like that's what
she likes though and she has like
someone well cuz boat rankings are like
a thing like a bow sin is underneath a
deckhand like whatever you know like so
the rankings are important like the army
no it's it's crazy so it was really
enjoyable I haven't really seen a lot of
sweet girls who the both sides know
there's like they always throw a one
random girl on the deck team just so
like say she had a lot of brothers you
know yeah that was below deck med there
was a girl on the deck team and there
was a guy on interior and she grew up in
the water you know and her brothers Rose
making fun of her so she's used to being
on the deck you know they always talk
like that like you could be a girl who
just wants to work on the deck you not
to give me anything so I grew up with
brothers and grew up loving the ocean
like you could work on the deck we don't
care right it was you like they had to
explain themselves it's like why they're
the only girl on deck
totally anyways what's up - Oh blow
decks on tonight yeah and yeah I have
such a busy day I'm getting my closet
Sam I imagined it done today hey fun so
the best yeah
I've got places to be people to go
places to be okay well then we'll wrap
up I have to go take probably the
biggest P of all time I'll record it I'm
gonna count what's the longest P you
ever made oh I don't know but sometimes
it's so I might count it I'm gonna count
when you wake up okay when you peel out
it also means you're losing weight no
it's not but that's not what it means
today like you see that big bottle of
seltzer I drink the whole thing before
the show and I didn't pick that's really
not even yeah no that's big no it's big
that's a water bottle no it's obviously
it's it's wrong okay okay guys well
don't forget tomorrow is merch day so
get excited we'll be posting the
products all day today they're really
fun and exciting I think you guys are
really gonna like them so that'll be at
shop morning toast comm unlimited
quantity for everyone panic will go live
as the show ends tomorrow so tune in
live tune in live tomorrow and we'll all
shop together and thanks listening to
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show that goes live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube and we're also available as a
podcast on iTunes itunes spotify stitch
or all the places you can listen so feel
free to subscribe there leave a nice 3d
telling us how beautiful skinny and
pretty we are Jackie and I actually read
the reviews of the podcast yesterday for
like the first time in the longest time
and there were so many reviews were like
beautiful skinny pretty thank you thank
you so much let me go we missed you and
we will see you tomorrow
you